[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils sont venus à tort de france au petit
balcon temple de la musique
traditionnelle compositeur musicien
artiste fans
il était là pour accueillir sa mère et
partager des moments d'émotion avec
chaque voisin
les ambassadeurs de la chanson française
l'artiste international avec une grande
simplicité à visiter le musée
s'intéressant à l'art la culture et au
patrimoine
puis marie ange rageait et lors qu'est
ce que la vieille garde ont accueilli le
chantre de la chanson française entouré
de représentants de la sacem non rythme
poésie expression du coeur se sont
relayés pour le bonheur de tous charles
aznavour avec son talent légendaire a
démontré que travail amitié respect
partage et convivialité se conjugue au
delà des frontières
c'est à ce moment travail a conclu liste
l'artiste peut dire j'ai vécu ou encore
on a toujours 20 ans
[Musique]
nous avons passé un moment ici
exceptionnelle avec charles naveau il a
joué avec barel coppet tu
il a félicité barel coppet taux sont son
roman sa sacralité de musiciens et
lâches ou et il a joué pour la première
fois je pense en public lui même il a
joué du piano sur le piano viella il a
joué donc il a chanté et c'était
vraiment une soirée exceptionnelle
toutes les personnes qui étaient là
étaient tranchantes et par la venue d'un
n'avons pas au mieux
[Musique]